when I was a little younger probably
around 13 or 14 I used to dress up and
go to the mall and walk around thinking
someone would discover me or something
and it never happened and I didn't think
I could ever model because you know I'm
a big girl
but surprise surprise now I'm a guest
girl that's it that's lovely hold that
beautiful
you're not laughing sexy sexy well
Playboy's kind of the girl next door and
I've always been really sweet I think
and guess
I don't know I think time's moving on
and they're having more women want to
see women with a body of today
you know instead of the
I don't want to get anyone mad at the
real skinny models
and I think I represent more of all the
women of today well there's something
magic I think uh that happens between
her and a camera
a lot of women are beautiful but that
that certain kind of uh Magic is is
special and she has that it is a dream
come true it's like a Cinderella Story a
love for my family to know that I made
it and and all the people that always
doubted me you know I had a lot of um
people who didn't think I was gonna be
anything growing up and they always
picked I had a lot of people pick on me
and stuff and
I just I want them to see you know it's
like my tell y'all it's been fun I mean
I didn't know someone could work this
much I hear they're fixing to do a movie
on Marilyn Monroe and if I don't get
that part I'll just die
I gotta have that part please if you're
listening to me I love my own she's my
dream come true
Show Business you're running
crazy and wild and
it's just work work and when you get
home we're so tired you just want to go
to sleep so when I come home it's you
know I got all my animals
horses and I don't know it just feels
really good it's a lot of peace and
quiet even though the cows are doing and
stuff but it's real peaceful and
I love it just hang out and have a good
time and
don't have to worry about dressing up or
talking right or
just have a great time
why have you have you come forward now
to to talk with us well I guess I'm
tired of I don't know everybody
basically
everything about me except for that I'm
not an alien or an alien's child I'm
supposed to be a Keanu Reeves girlfriend
I know I'd love to meet the guy on the
target for some reason you know the
reason I think I am a Target is because
I am a happy person and I am bubbly and
I tell it like it is and I'm very happy
and I think me I think that people hate
to see happy people
so they they dog you after you they say
oh come here let's do this interview and
you're like okay talking just to talk
you know and then later on they're like
Anna Nicole
overdosed or Anna Nicole this and that
and you're like
hello I had no clue I had no clue if if
I could take it back I'll be working in
Christopher chicken no you wouldn't yes
I would I would really I would you know
I'm thinking in my mind now man what a
life I had back were cook cooking
chicken
running up and down the drag you know
drinking beer great dumb
I met him at a topless Club what
happened was
um his driver used to come into the
place where I worked and Howard was his
girlfriend had died and he just had lost
his will to live
and he just brought him in there
to meet me I sit there and talk to him
and it was you know it's really been
nice to him and he started brightening
up you know and he's got this beautiful
blue eyes
and um that's how we met and uh
every day after that you know we went to
uh breakfast and then we started going
dinners and just every day for five
years then he always told everybody that
this is the woman that saved my life
and I'm very proud of that I fell in
love with him this is a man who took
care of me who took care of my son he
loved me unconditionally
he is always behind me very supportive
let me go do what I needed to do and
always told him I need wanted to make a
name for myself he was always the man
that said you go and you do what you
need to do I'm here
unconditionally
that's his words if he had been broke
would you have had the same feelings yes
I would well today the autopsy report
came in on her 90 year old
multi-millionaire husband you know the
big oil tycoon yeah seems he died of
acute allergic reaction to Silicon yeah
so apparently
at his memorial service you wore a like
a low-cut white gown and many people
felt that that was pretty inappropriate
for a memorial service
what was your thinking in that choice
and do you regret it how do you not
regret it
um my thinking at the time my husband
's death
I was totally devastated and then you
know he was so sick at the end of his
death and
I just I knew that he was going to a
better place I knew that he didn't want
me to be
sad it was more for him
and to the fact that he's going to to
the Lord and it's a joyous thing thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen you
know that Ovation lasted longer than an
Anna Nicole Smith morning period
[Music]
I don't care what people think you know
this is what I chose to do you know I
chose it and I know my husband would
have wanted me to do it the way I did it
please welcome Anna Nicole Smith
well she did send me some makeup which
I'm using MAC makeup it was great that's
right thank you very much for that well
you're welcome anything for you
sweetheart now we all know that you're
you were born Vicki Lynn Hogan did you
like Vicki Lynn I hated my name I never
went by my name it was always a
different name I went by so I mean you
could throw a million names on her yeah
I love I love Anna Nicole that's a
beautiful name you know it's funny
because
um Anna as soon as she appeared on the
scene there was a vulnerability about
her that you um you just want to take
care of her and you want you you feel
for like like a little girl everyone in
America really cares about Anna whether
I you know a lot of people in the Press
slam her but I tell you go from house to
house all over America everybody loves
her and it's for that one reason that
there's a vulnerability and there's a
kindness to her and and we always have
we everybody has a soft spot for the
underdog so I believe that Anna should
get whatever the hell she wants
it's true right here anna right here
another thing that I hate is you know
everyone was always dogging me because I
was heavy now
the Press doesn't praise me
for losing the weight
and I find that very
hateful I mean
they they want us they just want all bad
stories I mean give me a good one when
have I ever had a good story and I don't
know how long
you know
I lost the weight I did I did what what
the media in the industry wanted me to
do
and I just don't say any praise oh yeah
yeah
right in the middle you always want
to be in the Public's eye I mean you
always want to be there
but for some reason they're always mean
to me I don't know they just don't give
me a break they never give Anna Nicole a
break early this afternoon Anna
collapsed in her room at the Hard Rock
Hotel in Hollywood Florida an ambulance
was called and paramedics responded to
the scene at 2 49 this afternoon
we were advised by Hospital Personnel at
Anna Nicole Smith had died Anna was in
the south Florida area picking up a boat
for her new home in the Bahamas
Entertainment Tonight had the last TV
crew with Anna they talked about so many
things but perhaps the most powerful was
how The Grieving mother was haunted by
the death of her 20 year old son what
are your dreams about it's like he's
calling me come to him
yeah I can't scare
and he wants me to come to him
Daniel isn't this fun
[Laughter]
we were pretty stuck
I'm afraid
he doesn't know where to go
though he had 20 short years was he a
happy guy he was so happy
he was so happy
he didn't know at me and I don't
understand what God took him and didn't
take me
[Music]
clearly she knows her mom's looking down
on her she does she ever say anything
about that and the other day she had a
friend who's
um fish died and she said
um
she said don't worry about your fish
it's up there with my mom and um
said my mom's taking care of your fish
and if it's going to be okay
and so
you know it wasn't scripted it wasn't
something I said to her it was something
that she came up with and that's how she
deals with it and for that I'm proud
that she's um who she is I think there's
somebody up there that loves me and has
given me this chance because I've
struggled my whole life you know I had a
really rough childhood growing up and
I've I'm a very sweet honest nice person
I just I just I think I deserve a break
and I think someone's giving it to me
foreign